from usa today burger king uk under fire
for tweeting i can't read this quote
i'm gonna break the quote up so that no
one claims it came from me
women belong and this is burger king
in the kitchen and that's what burger
king said all right now i break it up
that way because someone's going to try
and pull out of context and try and make
it seem like i'm the one saying that i
do not believe women belong in the
kitchen i'm actually not i'm i'm a
proponent of uh women succeeding in the
workplace and getting beautiful salaries
and you know running companies uh uh uh
more to the point
we can all be proud of the fact that the
military-industrial complex is now run
by women exactly great strides in
blowing up children women are killers
too everyone oh yeah fantastic you know
but to be serious they can be you look
at how the prison system handles women
and they treat women with they get less
harsher penalties
in more lenient sentences than men
absolutely no women can be murderers and
criminals and all that really awful
stuff too they can be warmongers and and
uh you know weapons manufactures and all
that stuff and burger king
thought it would be a good idea to claim
that
they believed women
they believe belong in the kitchen
so usa today writes burger king's
attempt to highlight gender disparity in
the restaurant industry with a rock
provocative tweet appears to have
backfired on monday which is also
international
sorry on international women's day
burger king tweeted this out yup yup
some i i just i can't believe it a bunch
of like nationalists and like
pro-western personalities are saying
like thank you burger king for saying
what needs to be said this is exactly
what women need to understand and it's
like oh geez and the left is saying
you know apparently burger king is
defending themselves they're like it was
a good tweet that is bringing attention
to the issue that only 20
of culinary professionals are women
and then the left is just like so why
did you have to tweet
this sentence which is not in any way
conveying the message you think it is
if if if it had been me
i would have uh
i would have said that uh i just would
have called myself booker queen for a
day and then maybe that would have been
okay yeah that's a good idea parker
queen called a burger queen just burger
queen for a that's a good idea they
should hire you for marketing
i don't think they should
but i saw and i was like this is
this is hilarious and of course my
my my first thought was uh i mean you
know i i we got to keep a fam family
friendly it's it's so it's so difficult
for me but but it's it's just
it's just this this idea that um
you know it's like well
i i guess they they could be in in the
kitchen if if they truly want to be what
if they're choosing to be uh in in the
kitchen you know of course when i let
them out
that's right women have been fighting
for thousands of years
to to get out of the kitchen and fight
the patriarchy with a single tweet
burger king is trying to put him back in
the kitchen i know i know how dare they
no but it's even funny too like so what
burger king is basically saying is that
culinary professionals tend to be men
and i'm like
even even to that regard like is it
possibly because we have socialized to
the point where we're telling women not
to take these jobs and to be
professionals and go and work for bigger
corporations like we have been screaming
to our children
you know particularly young young girls
be the ceo be the high-powered attorney
be the executive and so i mean these
things have consequences
so now we're 20 years later and you have
a bunch of women who are going to school
specifically for
jobs that will make them a lot of money
and give them a lot of power in
corporations
not
culinary arts i think i think for a lot
of people
working as a chef in like the culinary
industry it's very much about a passion
for cooking and baking and creating food
and when you take when you take these
kids and you tell them you'll you won't
be respected you won't make money don't
do it what happens
you get a bunch of people who are like
i'm gonna do what i what i have fun
doing and what i enjoy doing
you have the stigma for the most part
for young women being told you have to
do more because you won't have respect
and let you take these jobs men aren't
hearing that so they're like i love
cooking i'm gonna go cook well it's it's
the strangest phenomenon and you know
i'm at an age now where i
i see a lot of new mothers and
i i become
disturbed on their behalf because
they actually feel guilty that they want
to spend more time with their children
and i'm thinking to myself isn't the
whole point of all of this is to is to
provide you with options so that if you
choose to you can stay home
and
i i
i think this also speaks to something
deeper and it's sort of related to
covert in a way like the the
the
instinct that so many people seem to
have to want to stay
just stay indoors and stay away from
just living their lives this devaluation
of life i mean my my thing is
yeah you know it's great if you have all
these degrees and all these
accomplishments
but
hey i mean every every new father i've
met has said yeah you know i
i i gotta keep working i wish i could
stay i wish i could stay home and be
with my kids like they understand the
sacrifice that they're making but i i
don't find as many women who
who understand that sort of cost benefit
now and i i wonder if it's because
they've been told all their lives that
they need to succeed and i'm thinking to
myself well we've known you know you
can't take it with you you can't take
all your degrees and all your money with
you but your children do live on after
you yeah i was doing these um
these are shakespeare sonnets and a lot
of them
have to deal have to do with
uh just fertility and uh um
carrying on your legacy in your lineage
and they're they're very wise you know
they're these 14 line poems and within
each of them you know he's addressing
you know somebody and at least in this
first chunk of them he's talking about
you know well you're young now but
you're not always going to be young and
when one of the best ones he says you
know well when you are old if you have
children then your your own youth and
that and the joyous time that you had in
your youth will be reflected back to you
and you can and you and that youth will
live and your own youth will live
forever through the youth of your
children they actually call passing your
wealth down to your child's succession
and that's success i mean the word
success comes when you succeed you're
sending all of your things to the next
generation but even then it's like you
know even if we're just talking about
material wealth i mean what other kinds
of wealth are there there's you know
what your philosophical wealth your you
know emotional wealth
your your ideas your your your
your your philosophies on life and these
are also things that you can pass down
to your children that that you can't you
can't earn in a workplace or at a
university you know what blows my mind
is we hear about this trope where people
are on their deathbed and they say you
know a person on their deathbed never
wishes they spent more time at the
office
the one thing we always hear is they
wish they spent more time with their
family and their friends and their loved
ones there's a story i was reading on
reddit long time ago it's about a guy
who said that i think it was his
grandmother showing him photos
of
uh him and his you know of his uncles
and his aunts or whatever at the grand
canyon or something and it was just a
picture of the grand canyon that was it
and the grandma looked at it and she was
like this is when you know i was with
your aunt and uncle at the grand canyon
and then she paused and said
why did i take a picture of the grand
canyon i don't care about the grand
canyon i care about your your your uncle
and your aunt or whatever and then he
was like now that was a the guy wrote
the story he was saying that was like a
profound moment for me where from now on
whenever i do anything the photos are
always of the people i'm with
not the things we've done or the places
we've been to that's peripheral that's
the outside the memories we have are the
people we love and care about so i'll
tell you what what really freaks me out
what i'm worried about
when
we constantly tell women that they
should be career women that
they're they're you know
there's a feeling some women have of
social stigma i'm not saying all women
i'm not saying it's something that every
woman experiences but i've seen uh the
conversations from from women who are
concerned that if they want to be just a
homemaker they'll be
in some ways socially
inconvenienced or face a detriment like
they could get divorced and then how do
they you know take care of themselves
they won't have respect from their peers
the issue i see is that
men don't have the same biological
limitation on having kids yeah you could
be 50 year old men and have kids but
women do have that limitation there are
ways to mitigate that with like freezing
eggs and things like that but that is
something men don't experience so i look
at these stories and i'm wondering if
like the reason why
perhaps i don't know i don't think it's
true i'm just it's something to consider
if people want to make sure they're
happy if maybe the reason why many women
aren't in the culinary arts is because
they're being driven
towards certain professions
men won't be negatively impacted they
can
trounce about waste time travel europe
and just do whatever they want because
they can choose to have a family at you
know any point yeah and these are there
are very different realities for women
call it the patriarchy call whatever you
want but there are certain privileges to
to being a man in terms of how much time
you have to figure things out one of you
know i
i have so much compassion because
um
i feel like women have a lot of big
decisions to make about
how they want their lives to be
and they have a limited window in which
to make those decisions and they also
uh
need to make those decisions at a time
where they don't really have the wisdom
you know what i mean none of us have
wisdom when we're 22. or the wealth yeah
yeah yeah you'd be a 50 year old guy and
have a bunch of money in savings but now
i can afford a kid yeah
yeah i was thinking regarding restaurant
work and what men and women that
in my experience they would stuff men in
the kitchen and women on the front in
the counter because women were beautiful
and made people want to buy more and men
were could handle the heat and the
grease and the steam and it's physically
toxic basically so it might be a kind of
job that men's bodies are just because
like it's like working in the iron mine
like you put the men in the iron mine
well that's the patriarchy
but it's also biological in a way i
don't know too much i'm sorry
ian are you implying that there's there
are differences between men and women
rhett weinstein yes
genetically yes let's get brett in
trouble whenever we have a sorry brad i
love you
well he's a smart fella so but i do i
would defer to him because it's like you
know if the experts are saying things
but no i think you're right it's it is
biological why is it that the service
industry is you know tends to be female
you go to a restaurant the serve the
serving staff it's not always not
absolute there's a ton of guys who are
waiters
but you'll tend to see women taking
service jobs
because
men will tip more probably or at least
as the assumption they do
so again at my job i see this play out
every single night you have these men
that show up
of
any age really
a lot of them older
and they're throwing all this money
around and you know
and
i don't judge because i see how the game
was played we have all of these these
young servers they're in their their
early to mid 20s and they're beautiful
and they had they each have their guys
come in and they have these men wrapped
around their fingers each of these men
come in saying like yeah i'm here to see
you know tatiana or whatever and they
they think that they you know that
they are special to her for for some
reason these guys and they're they're
kind of scumbag so they're going off and
they're doing whatever they want with
other women too but right but um you
know just what you were talking about
you know you know they they're making so
much money um and you know using
whatever that their whiles are and also
a lot of these guys come in they show up
i don't know if they're paying for this
company or if they're actually winning
this company uh you know but you know
these guys with money show up with women
that are half their age and it's a
really it's it's the kind of thing that
you read about and you're like that
doesn't really happen that often but
then you then you see it unfold and it's
kind of weird but it's like i guess i
kind of i kind of get it that's just
sort of how the game is played but it's
it's not something that people like to
talk about because it's not politically
correct i'm like well there's nothing
about about the interaction between the
sexes that is politically correct yeah i
i i can't remember what i was watching
but it was like some movie where there
was an old guy who hired a lady of the
night as it were he didn't want to hook
up with her he just like hung out with
her and talked about his day in his life
and it was basically like the the plot
line was videography he was like 60
years old he didn't have any friends and
he liked you know he felt
he got good feelings being the being in
the company of a young woman who he
could talk about himself and have
someone listen to him and i'm like for
these guys you call them scumbags
probably but i don't really see anything
all that nefarious or wrong when they
show up to this club wanting the
attention of these young women and
tipping them and giving them money or
whatever
you can argue it's transactional or
whatever but they're getting what they
want out of it they're getting
emotionally satisfied yeah they're not
doing anything illegal the women are
getting uh resources for providing that
level of like emotional comfort to these
guys so i'm like hey man and these girls
i mean look
we have to walk them to their cars at
night because like i said you know not
not the best kind of people that that
yeah
sometimes but you know they they're
driving nice cars they live in they live
in nice apartments i'm like look
you know do do what you can while you
got it and you know make make your money
i hope you you you know you're studying
something else but
again that's how the game is played and
people the people who want to shy away
from that but
see this is where the conversation
ignites a whole bunch of the like the
the gender ideologues that you're really
angry
because like we were talking about you
know women can only have kids first
amount of time they could freeze their
eggs but there still are even with
freezing eggs there still still are
implications for having kids at an older
age
and so what happens is we end up for a
variety of reasons of the institution of
marriage and you know i hear a lot from
conservatives they say that women should
uh be in the kitchen get married young
you know like i hear a lot from
conservatives they say women should get
married young and the reason
conservatives say this is that
as women age they become less valuable i
suppose so that's the idea that's tough
word to use but yeah well that's like
look you look at okay cupid well if
you're talking about the sexual
marketplace right right the biology of
trying to be very very precise with my
language here yeah we're i think we all
are at this point
we talked about it with jack okcupid put
out the data set showing that men just
message 22 year olds you can think it's
bad you can think it's wrong i
personally don't agree i i don't have
that preference for being a 50 year old
man i would not want to be you know in a
relationship with someone that young i'm
just would prefer someone closer to my
age but that's what the data shows and
you can't make all men change like the
ryan long sketch you know have you
considered telling me writing an article
about what women can do better yeah
like it's not gonna it's not gonna do
anything for you you know what i mean
so
this is this is why i think a lot of
people would argue that
marriage came about this way because it
provided security for the woman right so
they have access to that man who will
provide for them and it's assuming
you know the woman wants these things
they're
by all means women can do whatever they
want i just think that's one of the
reasons
it likely came about well it's funny
because then you know i i encounter
women uh oftentimes and
you know and again i mean this
it's a byproduct of just being a curious
person and when you and when you talk to
people and you know just
non-judgmentally and you ask them
questions you know and just over the
years i've heard a lot of women say like
you know what
i'm ready to just
not go to work anymore and just be and
just be kept and and not have to worry
about paying bills
they would never say that out in public
you know because they would get shrieked
at by their friends but
uh
you know i i do think that maybe more
women than not kind of feel that way
there's actually um i have to read this
paper but uh it's called the
the paradox of declining female
happiness whereas their
as their uh
i guess you could say their rights and
freedoms have expanded over the past few
decades since the 1970s they've been
self-reporting ever-increasing levels of
unhappiness right i think i read
somewhere else that um
about a quarter of women are on some
kind of um
either antidepressant or or psych or uh
psych medication or something like that
and
you know and and again i talk to i talk
to people and you know there's all these
stresses and all these things and they
they're inundated with this news about
how everything's wrong and everything's
oppressed and everything so i'm you know
i just
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you